- Hi, this is Thomas Lennon.
This is an @Midnight
Masterclass,
and I love wine.
I'm a wine enthusiast,
and today, I'm going to
show you just a little bit
about when you're tasting
wine so you can impress
your friends at
fancy restaurants.
But also, I thought
it would be fun,
since I'm already blindfolded,
to show you how to
escape if your hands
had been zip tied.
A lot of people smell corks
when they take wine.
People wanna act
like they're fancy.
So they go like that.
That is absolutely nothing.
You're never gonna really
learn much from smelling corks.
What you wanna do with
a cork is look at it
because you wanna
see if it's wet.
If the cork is dry, the wine
will be positively ruined.
A lot of people in
the world are snobs
about screw top wines,
but I'll tell you a thing
about a screw top wine.
You will never get a corked
bottle of wine with a screw top.
I swear to God,
I really felt like
their was a raccoon
sneaking up on me,
(laughter)
as this was happening,
but it was just the
sound of the cork
rolled off the table, right?
Okay.
So a lot of people look at wines
through, ah, you can
hold it up to the light,
and you're looking at
what's called the legs.
That means just how much
stays on the side of the glass
when you hold it up.
And it could indicate
that if there's like
tannins in the wine,
or if there's a lot of sugars,
if it's kind of like
a thick wine or not.
It doesn't necessarily
mean if it's good or bad.
It just is what
the legs look like.
And there's the nose,
where you kind of
smell the wine.
I stick my nose way in it.
Ahhh.
And I smell it really hard
because I did a ton of
cocaine in the '90s,
so I don't have the most
amazing sense of smell.
A lot of people spin it around.
The reason you're spinning it.
One, it's fun to do if
you've got attention deficit
and it's like a
little fidget spinner.
Two, it just is adding,
you're getting more
oxygen in the wine
and the air is opening it
up and letting it breathe.
And then, the finish is what
it tastes like on your tongue.
So you kind of get air.
What I always do,
and it looks sort of tacky,
but I literally just suck air
over the wine on my tongue,
but if you're in a
really fancy restaurant,
people will assume that
you know what you're doing
and they won't think it's gross.
(slurp)
Again, I did a ton of
cocaine in the '90s,
so it's taking me a second.
Oh, the other great
thing about wine,
is it gets,
as you do this and you
kind of be a smarty pants
with your friends,
it also gets you (beep) up.
There's a (beep) ton of
rules about wine, guys,
and I'm mostly a comedian.
Anyway, that's everything
I know about tasting wine.
Uhhhh.
Get (beep) up, guys.
Then (boom) get kidnapped.
And when you get kidnapped,
somebody might zip tie
your hands together,
and when you do,
what you wanna do is,
from way up high,
use the force of your body.
I'm gonna slam my hands
down across my midsection,
and basically use my
abdomen like a guillotine
to split me out of these.
And they can be as
tight as they want,
and they can be way
bigger than this, too.
And three, two, one.
Ahhh!
That's how to get
out of zip ties.
That's some of the
stuff I know about wine,
and this is an
@Midnight Masterclass.
I feel like the
@Midnight crew just found
an old napkin that's tied
around my face right now,
which is hilarious,
but I'm also a major germophobe,
so we'll see how that goes.
But I do feel like
this was just a napkin
that somebody found, right?
- [Crew Member] Uhhhhh.